okay thanks for coming i'm going to be
talking about
again deletion codes and the high noise
and high rate regimes and this is based
on
joint work with my advisor venkat guru
swami who's sitting over there
and i'll say what the title means as the
talk progresses
i'd like to first talk about what we
mean by the deletion model
so we just saw a pretty good
introduction of erasures
but let me say this again in for my
purposes
so if you have an erasure what's
basically happening is
i'm going to be transmitting a string
let's say of bits through a channel
and i expect perhaps some bad things to
happen and in the eraser model what i
mean by this
is that maybe these red colored bits are
going to have the information
that's within them lost and so
i won't actually know what's in these
bits and what happens to the receiver
is that i'm going to get some question
marks that tell me that the information
there is lost
again in words the symbols are lost and
i get question marks
to tell me that i don't know what's in
there
deletions are a related model so again
i'm going to be transmitting these bits
through a channel and now when i expect
something bad to happen to certain bits
of information i'm going to lose what's
there
but now instead of receiving question
marks to mark what's happened
the receiver is just going to get a
shorter string and this is all of the
bits
which were not which were not affected
when i went through the channel
so in particular i don't actually get
the question marks in the right
positions
all i have is the original symbols
and some are missing so again the
receiver sees nothing here
what i'm getting is a subsequence of the
message
so this is a version of erasers where
you don't get additional information
about what positions are missing so in
my example
there are eight positions missing and
they could have come from anywhere they
could have been the first eight
positions
the last eight positions or really any
subset and
as i stated this there's really no way
to know what's going on
so because of this this makes it a
strictly more difficult model
and to say a little more about what else
we think about this model
i'm only going to talk about pure
deletions i'm not going to
assume there are any errors or
insertions so although
what you receive is a subsequence and
it's much shorter than what was
originally transmitted you are getting a
pure subsequence
there aren't any everything you get is a
correct
symbol in its correct relative position
so i'm not getting anything any spurious
symbols added in
um also for decoding it will be helpful
if the receiver knows what the block
length is ahead of time so i'll just
make this assumption
and finally i'm only going to be talking
about the case of adversarial errors
so i want to be able to correct
deletions in the worst case
and since i'm going to be giving you
code constructions this means that this
is
a stronger result than if i'd stated it
only for random deletions
and finally why do we care about
deletions
uh at a high level this is just a really
good model for asynchronous channels you
can think of sending a stream of packets
some of which get dropped
and the point of an asynchronous channel
is that since
you don't really have synchronization
going on when a bit
that should have been transmitted is not
sent you won't necessarily know about it
until the end when you realize that
you're actually missing some of the
information you thought you were going
to get
and also from the theory side even
though deletions are superficially
pretty similar to erasures
the what we know about what is possible
against deletions
is really far from our understanding of
erasures
and there are a lot of just really nice
questions that are open still in this
model
which i'll outline at the end of the
talk
okay so i gave you this packet intuition
and from this you probably have realized
that
in some sense deletions are easy and
what i mean precisely by this
is that if i'm going to be sending some
message some string of symbols through
my channel
then one easy thing i can do against
deletions is just to put a header
on each of these symbols that marks the
position it belongs to
and if i do this and some deletions have
occurred all i need to do to address
this
is scan through the headers and look for
which ones are missing and this tells me
which symbols were affected
so in particular i've reduced the
problem down to erasures which we more
or less know how to handle
of course the problem is that i need a
different header for each symbol
position
so this makes the alphabet size grow
with the codeword length
which is something we don't necessarily
want to happen
the question we can ask is what can you
do if you're not allowed to just put
these headers on if you have if you have
constant sized alphabets and you expect
deletions to happen let's say at the bit
level
so you want really binary codes rather
than these codes with a
omega n alphabet size
let me say a bit about what is known for
this uh
for this regime so there has been a lot
of work on a constant number of
deletions for example what is the best
rate you can get
if there's only one deletion we're not
really going to be talking
about this we're going to be more
interested in a more standard coding
model i guess
of a constant fraction of deletions so
if i
drop a third of the symbols what can you
do
for random deletions we know a bit more
than we do for adversarial deletions for
example we
actually know that if the if you delete
each symbol independently with
probability p
it's possible to get a rate of one minus
p over nine
for nep so this is a result of mids and
mocker engineer from some time ago
and actually for low deletion fraction
which go to zero in the random deletion
model we even
know the exact capacity which is
basically one minus h of p
where h is the binary entropy function
and there's a lot of work to get to this
result one of the works is
by climate and macra and sudan
for adversarial deletions it turns out
that we know a bit less
what we do have is a construction due to
shulman and zuckerman which give
binary codes which have a constant rate
and can correct a constant fraction of
deletions
so although the explicit constants that
you get out of this paper are
relatively small this shows that you can
do something even in the model of
adversarial deletions
and this construction will actually be
the basis of what we do in our results
so what are we yes questions so that's
these are upper bounds sort of do you
have any corresponding overbounds for
these
for the right for the low deletion the
um this is tight there's matching upper
and lower bounds
for example yeah for random deletions
for the general thing i think
we don't really know general bounds yeah
they're pretty good
they're both pretty good upland lower
bounds and those are both constructions
for these but
divided by nine is somehow both
by uh kulkarni and kiawash which used
the
linear programming techniques which
unexpectedly came into the picture they
improved a bunch of levenstein bonds
so it's a recent paper maybe a year old
it's a very interesting paper i can give
you the reference by far
i think those are the best bounds for
adversarial
deletions right now
okay oh sorry so thank you for the
crowd yeah okay so
just as in pretty much every problem in
coding theory we just want to understand
the trade-off between the redundancy or
the rate that you need
and uh what kind of and what kind of
error correction capability you can
guarantee
so more specifically for this case what
i want to know is if i fix a deletion
fraction
p what's the best rate that i can
possibly hope to get that can correct
p fraction of deletions as i said this
has been a difficult problem
even in the random case and i'm going to
be talking about the adversarial case
so obviously something has to give here
and
for us what's going to happen is that
we're only going to talk about
sort of the two extreme values of p so
values of p
that go to zero and values of p that go
to 1. so we don't really
say anything meaningful about the
intermediate range of values
okay so the first thing you can ask if
you're interested in this question is
what is possible
combinatorially before you try to give
efficient constructions
and it turns out that constructing
deletion codes is not too difficult one
way you can do this is by a greedy
construction where you just grab a
string
and keep and keep taking more strings as
long as they're far away
from the current set that you have and
by far away i mean far in deletion
distance so this will just give you a
good deletion code and the point is it
turns out that you can
build quite a large code in this way so
for high deletions so the deletion
fraction going to one
you can actually get a rate roughly
which is constant and an alphabet size
which is constant and these have
fairly good exponents and in the low
noise case where the deletion fraction
goes
to zero you can get a rate of roughly
one minus two h of epsilon against a
deletion fraction of epsilon
so this is not too far from what we know
for random
deletions now notice that i stated this
first high noise result for uh for an
alpha size that grows with epsilon and
it turns out that this is actually
something which is necessary it's not
because we don't know how to analyze
binary codes in this case and the reason
is that if i allow
you to delete half of the code word then
you then in the binary case you can just
either delete all the ones or all the
zeros
and what you're going to get is either a
string of all zeros or all ones which
means that
you can only transmit one bit of
information and you can't ever hope to
get a constant rate
so if i want to correct a deletion
fraction bigger than a half even
approaching one
i do need an alphabet size that grows
with the gap to one
but if the alphabet size is larger
larger the overhead involving with
labeling the packets will be smaller and
smaller right in some sense
yes but we're still going to be using
yeah but we're still going to be using a
constant alphabet size
here it's 1 over epsilon cubed so the
overhead of n
for labeling is still pretty costly
yeah we're really interested in this
sort of constant gap like a one minus
epsilon deletion fraction where epsilon
will be constant
okay so what do we get so the first
thing we get for high noise
is that we actually construct an
explicit code which
qualitatively matches what we currently
know how to get with the greedy
construction
so we get a rate a constant rate in
alphabet size
against a 1 minus epsilon deletion
fraction and although our exponents are
slightly worse
the benefit of our code is of course
that it's explicit and has efficient
encoding and decoding
and similarly in the high rate or low
noise case we get a binary code with a
constant
with a constant rate with a rate
approaching one that can also correct a
constant fraction of deletions
and our rate is slightly worse than the
existential bound
but qualitatively we get the right
trade-offs
okay so how do we do this the idea is
concatenation
which probably most of you have seen it
has applications on a lot of other
settings
but just to go through it so far i've
given you two kinds of deletion codes
the first is good codes but over large
alphabets
which you can get by for example adding
headers to
acceptable erasure codes and the second
kind
is that if i use my greedy algorithm
then i can
construct good codes in fact over small
alphabets
and the only drawback here is that it
takes a very long time to construct
because i'm actually going to be pulling
each i'm going to be choosing each code
word individually
an idea of concatenation is that i'm
going to put these two codes together in
such a way that i can get
the best properties of both yes
yes you basically do the
use the same thing yeah so we're going
to use a very similar construction and
the idea is that we're just going to
essentially fix it up so that we can get
a high rate
a rate that approaches one instead of
losing constants in different steps
okay so how does concatenation work
basically i begin with my outer code
over this large alphabet so here's a
code word
b1 through bm of my outer code
and all i'm going to do is i'm just
going to take each symbol in this outer
code word and encode it separately
using my good code for the small
alphabet which i'll call the inner code
and i concatenate the results of these
which gives me a
longish code over the small alphabet
so to fix notation i am going to be
calling these uh
inner code words blocks throughout the
analysis so
hopefully that won't be confusing so
you'll notice that this is in fact a
code over a small alphabet
and as long as the alphabet size of the
outer code
is polynomial in the block length this
is also actually an explicit code that
you can
because the inner code is now over a
smaller block length
that you can brute force efficiently
so the only thing other thing that you
really want from this code
is for it to be able to actually correct
a reasonable fraction of deletions
it turns out that as i've stated it here
this is not necessarily going to be the
case
but let's try to understand how you
would attempt to decode these
concatenated codes
so they do so concatenate codes come
with sort of a natural
decoding algorithm and what happens is
that if i have this concatenation
of the encodings of different symbols
then what i can do for example in the
case of erasures
if some symbols are erased then all i
have to do is go through
and find out find what's left of each
block and attempt to decode it
so i'll just run the decoding algorithm
on the small blocks and get some sort of
some candidate symbols for
the outer code word and as long as there
aren't too many erasures
at the inner level then i'm going to get
a fair number of good symbols
given to the outer decoder which can
then correct anything else that's left
over
so this is fine unfortunately in the
case of deletions
um what happens is that if i have
something bad happening
in these symbols then it's not like i'm
going to be
in the case of erasures where i'm going
to get question marks to mark off what's
gone wrong
i'm actually going to in this example
for get this really weird substring
of what was of the concatenated code
word and the point is that i really
don't have a good way of finding out
which symbols belong to which blocks so
in the erasure case i just counted off
until the end
until the block length of the inner code
and then i would just decode what i
found there
but now i don't really have a good way
of identifying where the boundaries
between the blocks are so i'm not even
sure which symbols i should be
attempting to decode
so again if i but if i could find the
blocks then i can do a similar thing to
what i had for erasures
so my main challenge here is how can i
help the decoder locate the boundaries
between the blocks
and so for the rest of the talk i'm
going to explain our constructions which
are essentially giving us good ways to
try to distinguish
between different blocks
so the first result we have is for high
deletions and again
what we're going to get is a explicit
code that corrects one minus epsilon
deletion fraction
and gets a constant rate and a constant
alphabet size
so we're going to start off with just a
basic concatenated code we're going to
take
some good code say a read solomon code
at the outer level
and give it some headers so that we know
where everything is
and we'll concatenate it with a small
alphabet code that can correct a
slightly higher deletion fraction say 1
minus epsilon over 2.
and now as i said before our challenge
is that we need to somehow modify this
code
so that we can give the decoder some
assistance in locating where the block
boundaries are so they can try to decode
the inner code words
the idea that we're going to use is that
we're going to add
sort of constant size headers to each of
the symbols although we can't afford to
give
a header for although we can't afford to
give a different header to each block
what we can do is sort of give different
headers locally
so this is my concatenated code word
which is a string of encodings
what i can do for example is look in
this example i'll just color the blocks
i'll just alternate different labels so
i have
blue green purple blue green purple and
that means that locally my blue symbols
are distinguishable from their nearby
neighbors
and my hope is that this will be enough
to help the decoder
so what will the decoder do the decoder
is just going to use the colors or
labels on these symbols
to try to guess where the block
boundaries are so for example if i
receive
some string of this here is some string
blue some
string of green some string of purple
and
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
just run through this code word and
guess that the color boundaries are the
same
as the block boundaries and hopefully
this is good
so the way you're describing this you're
really dividing your alphabet into three
colors
essentially i'll use a different kind of
symbol for each color so yeah so you
would break
your you break your alphabet in a subset
so now you don't just add a little piece
of block in between well you can also
think of it
as putting a small header a constant
size header on each symbol
that says i'm a blue symbol
so which one do you do uh we use headers
i mean yeah it's basically dividing your
alphabet means all the symbols have a
property blue
yeah so the header will mark that i'm
blue but i can delete the header
well i mean i will make they'll be part
of the symbol basically
it's going to be yeah each symbol has a
header not each block
oh yeah sorry yeah each symbol has a
header
right so it's one of s1 square right
yeah i can afford to slightly augment
the alphabet
yeah that's essentially what's happening
right not quite because you give them
all the same
label right but it could have done then
just let's say i had it with two bits or
something and then just do a zero one
two three zero one two three right it's
not exactly
uh i mean in the implementation you can
sort of
choose how you do it right all i want is
to
because within the block here you have
no idea where each piece belongs
and the other one you do know that well
the inner code can correct deletions
already
so as long as i as long as i can locate
where the boundaries of the code word
are i don't really mind if
your construction there but more
generally i wonder if the other one
would be more efficient
where you uh label modulo within the
code
um the problem is we're dealing with a
constant fraction of deletions there's
going to actually be a lot of deletions
so if you label sort of within the block
how are you going to distinguish
different blocks
i mean it's it's all these constructions
are just extremely challenging to
think about so there are a lot of ideas
to try
you're always assuming that you delete
one block and if you put another it is
part of sorry one symbol and if you yeah
so the header is part of the symbol it
has to be
yeah so this construction only works for
large alphabet this is the same yes
i'll be giving a binary construction in
a second if i have time
your assuming a deletion process will
cooperate
and if it deletes the symbol it leaves
the header with it
yes so this is a large alphabet result
unfortunately
yeah as i mentioned you do need a larger
alphabet if you want to handle a large
fraction of deletions
i didn't understand why the high
deletion regime is necessarily tied to
the high
alphabet right so um so the idea is that
um
so for example in the binary case if i
am allowed to delete half of the symbols
i will just delete
any code word down to either n over two
zeros or n over two ones
so i get virtually no information from
the result
and in general for an alphabet a size k
i can't do better than one minus one
over k
so the alphabet does have to grow it
doesn't necessarily have to grow as fast
as we get the one over epsilon to the
fourth but it does have to grow
right or you look around right one hand
i'm going to be looking i'm going to be
looking at zero
yes so rate my rate is going to be for
this code is epsilon squared basically
if i wanted to look at minor alphabet
around rate one half
that is another question oh my god okay
i'll give you some slack for the
questions but okay
i can talk about this offline we
actually do have some results on binary
codes
with deletion near one half okay so
the receiver just goes through and looks
for colors and marks these as potential
block boundaries so to say the algorithm
more precisely
i'm looking i just scan through the code
code word just from left to right
and mark the color boundaries as
potential block boundaries and after i
do this
i attempt to decode each of the blocks
i've marked and this will hopefully give
me some symbols of the outer code word
and as long as enough of these blocks
were marked off correctly
and are just good blocks i'll be able to
get enough symbols so that the
outer code can hope to correct these and
so what i need to do
is try to is try to give a bound on the
number of blocks
that i can lose after the adversary
deletes these
yes output can also encounter deletions
yeah for example if an entire color
block was deleted
then my inner decoder is not going to
give me anything for that
yes so the for the outer code i'm going
to actually use i use the um
read solomon code with headers which can
handle deletions
which are essentially erasures if you
don't have the headers
so resolument codes are great they can
correct anything
okay so why is it that the decoder can't
affect too many of the blocks
um the idea is that he has sort of a
bounded budget of deletions and i'm
gonna show that
if he can only delete a one minus
epsilon fraction of the symbols
then he can't actually mess me up on
all of the blocks there's going to be a
constant fraction of blocks that remain
so to try to get a feel for why this is
true let me focus on this one block here
and think about what could go wrong with
my window for this block
so one easy thing for the adversary to
do is that he can just
look at this block and delete most of
the symbols in the block
and if he does this even if i even if i
set the block boundary correctly there's
just not enough information for me to
recover the block
so in particular i'll have lost that
symbol
and that'll be bad for the outer code
the thing is that i chose the inner code
to be a pretty good code
so this means i have to delete a lot in
fact since it
corrects slightly more than one minus
epsilon that means that
i can't do this on all the blocks in
fact there's going to be a constant
fraction that survives this process
now another thing that could happen
which is pretty plausible in the high
deletion case
is that the adversary could just
try to confu try to merge two of these
purple blocks
by deleting the entire blocks in between
and if he does this then i'm going to
get a long run of purple
and remember that my decoder is just
running through and looking for color
boundaries so he's going to mark a block
that contains symbols from both of these
inner code words which is bad for my
decoder which probably can't handle
something like this
so let's look back at what's happening
here we want to show it can't happen too
often and the reason for this
is that the adversary has merged
basically two blocks which is a
pretty small number and the price he's
paid for this is he's deleted
entire blocks between the two purple
blocks
and remember the thing is that in order
to remove the say the green block from
consideration
the adversary doesn't actually have to
delete the entire block
if he leaves up to say an epsilon over
two fraction of the block intact
i still can't guarantee decoding so the
adversary is paying a pretty high
penalty in deletions
in order to just merge two blocks
together
and this means that as long as i set the
number of colors to be high the penalty
that the
that the adversary is paying to cause
these merges is very high
and this can't happen to too many blocks
so if you set the parameters correctly
you'll be able to show that there's
going to be a constant fraction of
blocks that survive
and in particular this gives you your
constant rate code over a constant
alphabet that corrects a very high
fraction of deletions
okay so our second result is high rate
binary deletion codes
um so there is a code that has a high
rate and can correct a constant fraction
of deletions
this is strongly based on the
construction of schulman and zuckerman
but modified so that it can actually get
a high
rate because the original construction
loses constants in a couple of places
which is basically what we're going to
optimize here
so similarly we're going to begin with
with some
outer code say read solvent code that
has headers and i'm going to concatenate
with an
inner code that corrects a slightly
better fraction of deletions than what i
hope to correct
globally and the key observation for us
is that i can actually choose the inner
code to be dense and i won't say exactly
what this means but
as long as you look at long windows in
the code word it's going to have high
hamming weight so there'll be a lot of
ones in this
and in the shulman zucchini case what
they do is just
put ones in every other symbol we're
going to be a little more careful to try
to keep the rate high
so again the challenge is to try to make
it so that the decoder can distinguish
blocks
and the way we're going to do this is
just by adding buffers of zeros
in between the blocks so if the blue
blocks represent
uh my dense inner code words i'm just
going to put a reasonable length of
zeros between them
and since the code words are dense they
have a lot of ones in all the
in long windows that means that in some
sense they look very different from the
buffers
and that's what i hope to use at the
decoder
what the decoder is going to do is it's
just going to look for long runs of
zeros
and pray desperately that these are
actually buffers
so if i get sort of this with the blue
blocks representing
reasonably balanced strings and then
these long runs of zeros
i'm just going to assume that these runs
of zeros are in fact buffers
so to state the algorithm more precisely
i'm going through and looking for
sufficiently long runs of zeros i mark
these as buffers
then i attempt to apply the inner
decoder to all of the blocks between the
buffers
and i hope that i get enough symbols to
actually uh
be able to pass to the outer decoder to
correct
so again i will be able to decode if i
get enough correct windows
and i just need to talk to balance the
number of windows that the adversary can
mess us
up on so again we're going to say that
with the budget of only a really small
constant fraction of deletions the
adversary can't really mess us up
on too many of the blocks
so again let's focus on just one of the
blocks
which lies between two buffers one thing
that could happen to this block
is that the adversary can just go and
delete most of the buffer
and if the adversary does this then um
when i run through the when the decoder
runs through the code word then
these two inner code words will actually
be merged and i'm going to mark no
buffers in between them
which means that i've now merged these
code words and probably my decoding will
fail
but this requires you to delete most of
the buffer as long as you set the buffer
to just be
slightly to be slightly longer than
the fraction deletions you're trying to
correct that means this is costly and
actually most of the buffers are going
to survive
and that means that you're going to mark
most of the blocks roughly correctly
so the other thing that could go wrong
with
with after the adversary deletes
something is that actually
um there can be deletions within the
code word
and one of the most devious things the
adversary can do is to
for example choose the symbols at the
beginning and the end of the code word
and actually just delete all the ones
from these from these uh
initials from these uh segments and if
the adversary does this
then to my decoder it looks as if these
zeroes are part of the buffer
so i'll actually mark a window that is
noticeably smaller
than the number of symbols that actually
survived
but luckily since i chose the inner code
word to be dense
that means that if i wanted to create
these long runs of zeros within the code
word
it would cost me deletions of many ones
because i'm looking at these long
windows which
i've required to have high hamming
weight
so in particular again if you set the
parameters uh
very carefully then you can then you can
show that
both of these cases are pretty rare as
long as the adversary can't make too
many deletions
and so you actually have a high fraction
of the symbols decoded correctly and
sent to the outer decoder which
which can then fix anything else that's
gone wrong with the code word
okay so i just gave you some
overviews of good deletion codes that
can handle high noise and high rate
but of course there's still a lot that's
open for this model so one of the
most basic questions is for binary codes
what is the highest
deletion fraction that you can correct
with a constant rate and the best
bounds we know really are that it's at
least 0.17
and the only upper bound we really have
is that is the one half upper bound i
told you
where i said that if you're allowed to
delete more than a half you're just
going to
delete down to all zeros or all ones so
this is something we don't really know
and of course we don't know this for
fixed alpha size k
either we don't even understand how it
behaves asymptotically as k grows
of course one can ask whether we can
improve the rate of our constructions
this is something that you can't do with
concatenation because
both of the both the inner code and the
outer code suffer a loss and rate
which compounds when you concatenate so
you need
new ideas to get improved rates for this
hey thank you
any more questions
yes it's the greedy construction that i
described to you so that's another
um issue with our construction is that
the uh construction time is pretty high
actually
although it's it's one of those
questions of whether
efficient is the same as practical so
the other question all right you said
you had some results regarding the half
point in binary code yeah so actually
what we have
is essentially that we can list decode
up to a one-half fraction deletions for
binary codes
and just to quickly say the intuition is
just that our problem is always that we
can't find block boundaries and if
you're list decoding
then you can actually try different
block boundaries and get different
guesses for each of those so that allows
us to get all the way up to one half
unfortunately we don't know if that's
necessary like we get a pretty long list
maybe
you can actually get a list of size one
and we just have no idea how to do it
so this size is a function of the
distance to half yes
what's the function um
some polynomial in uh one over epsilon i
think but
and the code is the same
yeah essentially at this point it's
important to use a
read solvent code at the outer level
since we know how to do list recovery
for them
so so for the 0.17 is that by
mitsumocker yeah